Speaker 1: All right, let's get
into some really, really dangerous,
ignorant, pathetic, delusional and even
dangerous reactions to the news of the last
48 hours of the full approval of the Fizer
covid-19 vaccine. We predicted and many others
did as well. It was obvious that as soon as the
Fizer vaccine was fully approved by the FDA,
the goalpost would be moved by the anti vaccine
crowd and all sorts of new conspiracy theories
would come up. I'm going to play for you today.
This is video I always struggle with explaining
exactly what this is. This is Steve Bannon's
show, former Trump advisor Steve Bannon's show,
The War Room on Real America's Voice. And I don't
know if Real America's Voice is a cable channel or
just a YouTube channel or maybe they're not even
allowed on YouTube. I don't really know. Steve
Benen invites Dr. Gina Loudon on to talk about
vaccine approval. Now, you know where this is
going. If I tell you, we will be speaking to Dr.
Gina Loudon about the vaccine approval process,
you would sensibly assume that we're talking about
a medical doctor here, especially after the right
said what, sir? Why do they call her Dr. Jill
Biden? I mean, she's a Ph.D. in education or of
educational doctorate. They would never do that.
Well, no, they are actually. Gina Loudon is a
she has a Ph.D. in organizational systems from an
online university. An online university. Come on,
guys. Come on. OK, so let's get into it. The
claim from Dr. Louden is the vaccine is not really
it's not really approved. And now, of course,
it is approved by the FDA. She says it's not
really approved. And she brings something up
about the placebo group. And there's actually a
really interesting topic here to discuss. Let's
listen and then we'll discuss where are the
Speaker 3: grassroots mothers today and what
Speaker 1: can our audience as an activist
audience, you, by the way, why do all of these
people, Alex Jones and Banan and on Shroyer,
what's with the whole grassroots? It's like
it's like Sean Connery. All the conspiracy
theorists are like Sean Connery. Let's continue.
Speaker 3: You know that they love you. What can
this audience do today to start to defend
against this? Right. If they're uncertain,
if they don't feel they have
the information, what do you
recommend our audience members do, Doctor?
Speaker 4: Well, first of all, you have to
speak up. You have to say things like referring
to this NPR article by Richard Harris from
February 19th. They dissolved the control group.
Speaker 1: And we're going to talk about that
because she's completely misleading this study.
Speaker 4: So for the FDA to have approved
this without legitimate data using a
control group, they lost the control
group in the middle of the study.
Speaker 1: She is lying. She is lying
Speaker 4: and is reprehensible. So this is
not really an FDA approved shot. Right. So
that's one thing, huh? You have to go. I think
rational ground dotcom is a great place to go
to get real information on a lot of this.
Speaker 1: That's not true. Rational Ground
is a nutty website which promotes the ideas
that masks are bad, social distancing is bad
ever. Closing anything is bad. So that's not a
reputable website. We'll go we'll go to actual
peer reviewed studies in a moment.
Speaker 4: They've taken them off
of social media like they do so many.
Speaker 5: But I went, whoa, whoa, whoa, hey,
whoa. Hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on, hang on.
Speaker 3: What do you mean?
This is not FDA approved.
Speaker 1: Yeah, what? Doctor, please tell us.
Speaker 4: Dr. Jean-Noel. FDA approved.
Oh, but it's FDA approved in a way that
no other medication has ever been approved. Eli,
you want to refer to the article? This is not me
talking. This is an article by Richard Harris.
Speaker 1: Well, we're going to
look at the article
Speaker 4: on NPR February
19th. You can read it yourself. They lost the
control group in the middle of the study, but
Speaker 1: they lost them yesterday. I
lost one of my earbuds. They just lost
the control group. They couldn't find it either.
Speaker 4: They decided it was more important
that people went and got the job then that they
finished the study with an actual control group.
Speaker 1: Oh, wait a second. So. Oh, that's
something different. So this is I found the
article. It's an NPR article. So what what
was she right about? It's an article in NPR.
It really was published on February 19th, and it
really is by Richard Harris. But what the article
explains is that the vaccine was working. And as
is the case in many of these Phase three trials,
when what you're testing works
so much better than the placebo,
there is a medical ethics question about is it
even moral to keep giving people only the placebo
when giving them when the efficacy signal is so
high that you're potentially killing people by
not giving them the real vaccine? And this is a
widely studied a topic in medical ethics. Just
as one example, even as it relates to the
covid vaccines, there is a study in JAMA,
one of the premier medical journals from December
of last year, the ethics of continuing placebo in
sars-cov-2 vaccine trials. And what is important
to talk about is what's in this second paragraph.
According to Pfizer Biotech and Moderna
interim analyzes, after approximately two
months of follow up, suggests the vaccines are 90
to 90 percent effective at preventing infection.
Although no peer review of the data has been
conducted to date, both companies now claim they
have an ethical obligation to offer vaccines as
soon as possible to all participants who receive
placebo, considering the strong results and
participants contribution to the research. This
is not a new issue in medical science when there
are rules for how you test things and one is you
test things versus a placebo, you consider what
is if there is an effective treatment already,
you test them relative to the best treatment we
have. You want to demonstrate this not only works,
but it's better than the best thing we have
right now. And it's extraordinarily dangerous
now to come up with. They lost the control group.
No, the vaccines were so effective. And remember,
at the time this was pre Delta variant.
The efficacy has come down against Delta,
still very good against hospitalization and death.
The numbers after two full months were so good
that they made the call that it would have
been unethical not to give the people who
got the placebo, the actual vaccine. These
people are very, very dangerous. And remember,
they were furious that Jill Biden was being
called Dr. Jill Biden because her doctorate is in
education. This is Dr. Gina Loudon talking about
vaccines. Jill Biden wasn't even commenting on
medical elements. This is a woman, Gina Loudon,
who's actually opining about vaccination and
they call her doctor. She has an online Ph.D. in
organizational psychology or something like that,
completely immoral, completely dangerous
and completely hypocritical as well